good evening I'm Anne Thornton vice
provost and university librarian here at
Columbia University and I would like to
welcome you all to tonight's event the
seventh annual Norman Alexander lecture
in Jewish Studies this event on an
annual basis celebrates the Norman
Alexander foundation's generous
endowments to establish the Norman
Alexander library of Jewish Studies and
to establish a position for the first
librarian for Jewish Studies at Columbia
University
a third Alexander endowment supports the
libraries Rare Book and Manuscript
Holdings including important Judaica
resources and Hebrew manuscripts one of
the largest collections in the country
and over 200 of which we have completely
digitized and made available online
thanks to the generosity of the Norman E
Alexander foundation Columbia University
has become internationally known for its
Jewish Studies collections we
participate in local and global
partnerships including a cooperative
project with the National Library of
Israel to make important early
newspapers from the American Jewish
press freely available online
additionally thanks to a grant from the
National Endowment for the Humanities we
are creating online access to data
gathered as part of the language and
culture archive of Ashkenazic jewelry
project carried out by scholars at
Columbia between 1959 and 1972 this
extraordinary resource will provide
access to the spoken language of
surviving post-world War two Yiddish
speakers from over 600 locations in
Europe preserving an endangered
linguistic and cultural legacy we hope
that the detailed interview material
that's digitized in this project will
ultimately be linked to the over 5,700
hours of
do tape field interviews with
yiddish-speaking informants from the
same collection under the expert
curation of michelle chaz nur the
library continues to add to its rare and
unique holdings one of our newest
acquisitions is a Pincus book from 1772
to 1818 for the city of petit Glee on O
and Tuscany which has a long history of
Jewish inhabitants in addition to
celebrating the normani Alexander
foundations great gift to Columbia's
libraries this annual lecture also
signifies the library's enduring
commitment to supporting the field of
Jewish Studies at Columbia University I
want to thank especially Norman
Alexander's daughter Gail Ben Derman who
is with us tonight for her enthusiasm
and support of the collections and its
related programs and now I would like to
present the normani Alexander librarian
for Jewish Studies Michele Chas nur who
will introduce tonight's speaker
good evening
Alexander : fellow of the sari of the
ark I'm gonna get this wrong of the
American Institute for architecture is a
noted architect urban planner design
critic and author his principle of
Alexander Gore lay and architects
founded in 1987 and specializes in a
wide range of design programs that span
the economic and cultural spectrum
including religious institutions schools
high-end residential affordable and
supportive houses for the homeless
Alexander Gulen holds architecture
degrees from Cooper Union and the Yale
School of Architecture and was a Rome
prize fellow at the American Academy in
Rome he's the author of five books
including two on the contemporary
American townhouses and most recently
and Kabbalah in art and architecture
which won the National Jewish Book Award
in 2013 and is the topic of tonight's
talk mr. Berlin thank you very much and
I'm very honored to give the Norman
Alexander talk this year and especially
grateful for his generosity and that his
daughter is here I am very proud to be
giving this talk so until recently
Kabbalah was limited in study to
righteous men over the age of 40 however
this this group as you know has been
dwindling rapidly and so in the news
Madonna and a number of her celebrity
adherents have embraced a form of
Kabbalah that has raised the awareness
of this mystical aspect of Judaism and
at least that allows for other people to
then study in different levels of depth
but at least she has raised the
awareness of this another is David Bowie
was actually shown here drawing the tree
of the Saffir out which very few people
know that he was also very involved with
the Kabbalah my own interest came not
from Madonna or David Bowie but from as
an architect I was asked to design a
synagogue in Kings Point Long Island and
I had never done one before I had done
residential work housing but I at least
I knew that I did not want to do a
burning bush motif which was a
commonplace in the 50s and 60s and so I
was looking for other areas of
inspiration and I happened to open up
the works of Gershom Scholem who has
popularized a more academic study of
Kabbalah in his book Jewish mysticism
from 1941 and so when I to my great
surprise I found a number of ideas in
Kabbalah that relate directly to art and
architecture to light to space to
geometry as well and so specifically
this was in Kings Point which was
originally the East Egg of of the Great
Gatsby a former anti-semitic community
however Jews are now welcome except for
Orthodox Jews and so the surrounding
community did not want to allow a
yeshiva to turn to take over a public
school and this court case went to the
Supreme Court and it was allowed to
expand the various parts of it including
the sanctuary that way I was asked to
design but it was highly limited and
compressed in height to actually the
level of the street and below so my idea
was how do you bring light into this
under underground space and I was
specifically inspired by which I'll talk
about in more detail later the themes of
Isaac Luria the idea of that simsim or
the contraction at the beginning of
creation that leads to the vessels of
light that then shatter and this idea of
a shattered vessel of light
became the idea of a shape a space that
was broken open by light and created by
that that that energy and the arc itself
I placed in the corner but as a as a
kind of glowing luminous cube of light
with two inverted triangles that only
from the point of the beam up coalesce
into the net into the mug and of it the
Star of David and then at the same time
I used the tree of the severe oat as the
the design for the arc for the the
curtain of the arc so the all of these
themes then alerted me to ideas of the
Kabbalah which I then studied in more
depth and to my surprise also I found
that there were many artists who had
been using themes of the Kabbalah
for many years including and some Keifer
who was a german artist who perhaps in
his the guilt after postwar germany has
used themes of jewish thought in his
work in a critical manner this is from
the this is from the exhibition in 2010
at the go-go's ian gallery called the
Shekinah
or the feminine aspect of god where he
used uses the bride's dress with the
shards from the fractured vessels of
creation out of which grow the diagram
of the severe out the which I'll show in
a few minutes so what is the Kabbalah
this is a an engraving by the British
artist Blake that shows the Ancient of
Days but it also implies the idea of
creation of God emerging from the void
creating light and using God as the
architect of the universe always one of
my heroes as an architect of course
today he would use a computer but at
that time he used a triangle to create
the geometric forms of creation he also
actually
she has all the the circle the square
the right angle of his beard and arm and
the triangle but the themes that are
illustrated in a way first of course the
Kabbalah means that is where is that
which is received in Hebrew and it's
also the name above the reception desk
Kabbalah in Israel so the it's actually
a very common word it's also a receipt
that one gets in a taxicab so it's not
always a mystical ride but it's
definitely the same word that's imbued
with different meanings over time so the
mystical system is a theosophy that is
it deals with the inner workings of God
and how does his energy become manifest
in the world it's also a path for the
initiate stew actually directly
experience God through a series of very
difficult mystical exercises it's also a
theory of interconnectedness where God
and humanity are connected in unexpected
ways so that human action actually has a
an effect on God which later I'll show
is the idea of tycoon that the repair
which is a obligation of mankind to
repair the shattered world of the
universe so that God actually needs man
to complete the the universe and also
the Torah is the Word of God and
therefore every paragraph every sentence
every letter is sacred and embodies like
DNA the secrets of the universe and that
the universe was created in Hebrew not
in translation and so the Hebrew
language actually has magical powers to
each letter that are also symbolic and
related to gamma tria or the assignation
of numbers to each letter where the
concept of let's say for example hi
which is a team comes from and then
finally the idea of
the whole universe is also a code for
the name of God which comes in various
combinations from the four-letter
Tetragrammaton the urine hey've of hey
the 12 letter the 42 letter and even the
72 letter grand name of God all
unpronounceable of course the 72 letter
name makes a very good password for your
computer if you can remember it so also
in the Kabbalah there are four worlds of
four layers of reality in the world the
world of action of materiality in which
we live the world of angels the world of
formation of the throne chariot of God
and the world of emanation of the
internal workings of God and how the
energy is brought to the world as well
there are four levels of meaning to each
of these four layers per shot which is
the literal that is the world is fifty
seven hundred years or so years old
REM is the metaphorical and gamma tria
jarash is the detailed interpretation
and soda is the secret ultimate meaning
all together this acronym spells remiz
of a per shot remiz drache and saad
spell par des which is the orchard or
the the garden which the Kabbalah is is
likened to so the entering of the
orchard is considered how one enters
into the mystical system and there's a
story where four rabbis there's always
four enter the orchard and only one
leaves safe one dies one becomes a
heretic one becomes mad and only Rabbi
Akiva leaves the orchard safely so the
idea of psychic as well as physical
danger has always been associated with
the study of the Kabbalah and there are
two passages in the Bible that are
considered pre Kabbalistic that are
forbidden
was the study of the beginning of beret
sheet of the story of creation and the
other is the beginning of the Book of
Ezekiel the first paragraph of the
throne chariot of God in which Ezekiel
sees this vision when he's exiled from
Israel where he sees the four creatures
the Eagle the Ox the angel and the eagle
and the lion holding aloft the throne
chariot of God each of them has wheels
within wheels with eyes on the rim and
each of the four creatures has four
faces so this mystical vision whose
meaning it was never clear became the
inspiration for a whole series of hakalo
or ascension to the palaces of God and
how when ascends to have contact
directly with the deity and this is a
Blake it has also related that ascension
to heaven of Jacob's dream of the angels
that are ascending and descending the
ladder this is unlike sillas tration of
that of the angels the dream of Jacob
and this is a modern interpretation of
that theme this is Kusama
the Japanese artist called tender is the
ladder to heaven so the the idea is that
many of the these artists some are
explicit in their reference to Kabbalah
and others illustrate the idea
this is Sai guo chun also Chiney that
he's chinese and this is a ladder to a
sky ladder to heaven in which held aloft
by a balloon is this ladder that then
ignites so it becomes this fiery ladder
directly to heaven so now the main
themes basically from the laurianne ik
school of thought who was a rabbi from
the mid 16th century who reinterpreted
or brought many of the ideas of of
medieval Kabbalah
and his interpretation so his the first
is the symptom which is the idea of the
void or if there's God is everywhere
where is there space for creation so he
posited this idea of rather than an
active gesture like in beret she'd let
there be light he posited the idea of a
contraction or our withdrawal in fact
it's the idea of abstraction also
because in Latin abstractors means to
withdraw from so perhaps that as we'll
see is why this theme has inspired many
abstract artists so this this space that
God creates away from himself he kind of
exiles himself from this void space into
which the first rays of light bounce
around this is the void theme from 1989
by anish kapoor who's an indian artists
who's actually his mother is Jewish but
he did a series of voids in which the
idea of this absorptive absorptive black
hole of space clearly illustrates the
idea of the that simsim or that void at
the beginning of creation and barnett
newman who was an artist from the 1950s
an abstract expressionist he often used
some Kabbalistic themes I mean he was
eclectic he also had Christian themes as
well but this is this is actually named
the zum-zum variation of the symptom in
which he has these folded plates of
Steel of Corten steel that create this
space in between these these walls to
meto give the kind of equivalent of the
idea of that contracted space in which
light then emerges and this is one of
the the leaps of kind of thought that I
had was finding actually architectural
examples that mirrored certain ideas of
painting that all of which Illustrated
these couples
themes this is the Salk Center in La
Jolla California by Louis Kahn Khan was
a great architect who he also did the
Yale Center for British art but his Salk
Center has laboratories of folded
concrete that looked toward the Pacific
Ocean and frame a view of the Pacific
and of this space in between creating
this courtyard as a void that is sliced
by a cube of travertine from which water
emerges like Moses striking the rock
that then water issues from and that
slices the the space in to and unites
the earth the Pacific Ocean which is
here the Sun sets directly on axis at
the Solstice and so this in a way is the
equivalent of the symptom that also
barnett newman shows so clearly and then
at night it even becomes more clear like
this slice this sword of light this
chalice that points to heaven and then
this is Barnett Newman's one mint from
1953 where he explored the same idea of
this broad field of the blue void of the
sky that spreads out but then is sliced
by the zip as he called it of light that
again recalls the idea of the symptom
and the emergence of light in 1963
Newman for the new architecture for at
the Jewish Museum he showed new
synagogue architecture he did a proposal
for a synagogue that was a cube that
from the side was cut by this folded
plane which he actually calls that
symptom here this folded diagonal line
and again as an eclectic artist he was
not he did not want to be related
completely with Jewish thoughts so he
called he called the inside also dugouts
he combined baseball and a synagogue
so the Bema is the pitching mound over
here the mound
and these are dugouts where the people
stand to watch the the prayer service
where the pitcher the individual stands
before God like the like the pitcher at
a baseball game but what's interesting
is that he cuts open the sides with
these folded planes that he called the
sim zoom and that also relates in a way
to Daniel Lee busken's Jewish Museum of
Berlin where he uses the diagonal folded
line as a kind of dagger in the heart of
the city to to keep the memory of the
Jews that perished during the Holocaust
and in fact cutting that diagonal is the
Holocaust room that goes right across
the the diagonal lines of the museum and
within there's the Holocaust Room which
is this a grim space lit from above
claustrophobic feeling like the like one
is in the grave again trying to recreate
the feeling of being a victim and
keeping the memory of the Holocaust
alive in in the heart of Germany also
the idea of the void is in Peter
Eisenman's monument to the murders Dru
murdered Jews of Europe near the
Brandenburg Gate where he cuts he has
2,400 cubes which he then actually
realized later is almost as the same
number as the tractates of the Talmud
and it's cut by these paths so it gives
the impression of a of a cemetery many
of you I'm sure have seen this but you
walk through this tilting plane in
between these gravestones that are
anonymous there are no names on it that
give the feeling of unsettled memory of
of time that has and the Holocaust that
has been commemorated so within that
void within that symptom light now
emerges in points of light that bounce
back and
fourth and eventually create the pattern
of the Saffir oat there are ten Saphira
which is the tree like diagram that
shows how the energies of the divine
light emerge and come down to earth so
they take the the they take the form in
a diagram of the Tree of Life and
actually it's called usually it's the
way it's described is actually upside
down that the branches are above and the
light comes down but it's often mostly
drawn above like this so I'm so is the
infinite or the unchanging power of the
divine is above the Saffir out and they
add the path the the light then draws
down into ket air which is the crown and
into a series of balanced for example
guevara or judgment is balanced by mercy
so left and right they're balanced and
also up and down from the highest to the
lowest and the lowest is closest to the
earth to the people of Israel this is
the Shekinah or the feminine aspect of
God and so the idea of of the feminine
is introduced into God so it is not is
not considered simply a male deity now
this form of the tree of the Sufi wrote
is also shown as a concentric ring where
each of the letters is wrapped one
within the other now this is the plan of
a looook on synagogue mikveh Israel that
was never built in Philadelphia that
clearly takes the plan of the tense of
fear out there are ten light towers that
are round so the idea of the ten the ten
luminous spheres of light that define
the severe out-con reinterprets as a
plan of the of the synagogue itself and
the arc is over here and you're
surrounded by these towers of light that
from the out draw outside are a fortress
but internally are these very light
filled mysterious shapes that define the
interior space and these are all
drawings of unfortunately wasn't built
because of course it became was
phenomenally expensive so mysticism has
a price to it this is another diagram of
the Sofia wrote as is conceived a
concentric rings ten rings from the
aint south to the the exterior and this
is by Ken Noland also an abstract
expressionist from the 50s which also
has 10 rings surrounding the center
circle and it's called beginnings and
it's about the pulsing idea of the
beginnings of of light and energy this
is another diagram of the Saffir out
held this is from actually 1513 so these
abstract diagrams were really
Illustrated from the earliest times they
were abstract completely abstract in the
manner in which they diagram energy flow
interconnectedness the relationship of
man to God and they they are actually
they're also the basis of the idea of
the Madonna Kabbalah which is really
basically light and love and so how to
bring the light down into our
environment but they really keep it much
more surface like that this is the this
is the antomium from the 1958 Brussels
World's Fair that recalls that shape of
the interconnected spheres of light it
was actually an enlarged carbon atom but
it was the idea of the peaceful use of
atomic energy
but clearly the idea of the
interconnectedness of energy throughout
the universe
now the vessels of light are an
interpretation of each of the Saffir out
that emerge within the simsim and this
is the one that clearly has most
implications for architecture because
architecture
is very much about how light shapes
space and form and call grade architects
have talked about that but the Kabbalah
is makes specific reference to these
concepts that then architects
reciprocally can use in their work this
is from the Sarajevo Hagaddah showing
the creation of light and the first few
days of creation shows so within this
dome the separation of light from dark
the waters above from the waters below
the creation of vegetation but again
even though this is from the 1300s in a
very abstract manner now this is James
Turrell who has used light as the theme
of his sculpture and this is one of the
rooms that was at the Guggenheim Museum
show a few years ago he calls them the
ganzfeld rooms where you actually enter
and you're completely suffused by light
without any sense of edges so that
you're in a sense become like a being of
light within this space that Tyrell
creates so it's the closest to the idea
of like being within that vessel of
light at the time of creation when these
the light first emerges and this was the
the Guggenheim itself where he
transformed the whole shape of Wright's
interior in again emphasizing the idea
of a vessel of light now Wright himself
actually did design a synagogue this is
from 1958 it's one of the last buildings
he designed it was in Elkins Park near
Philadelphia and the rabbi Mortimer cone
is one of the few clients that ride
acknowledged as an inspiration for his
architecture usually he ignored what his
clients said or wanted but in this case
he actually deferred to the rabbi who
told him he wanted a traveling Mount
Sinai of glass so he actually he
actually said explicitly he wanted a
luminous glass structure which right
then
interpreted it in its own manner in a
series of in the hexagonal geometry that
again relates to the mogen David Wright
in fact worked in either circles squares
or in hexagons in this case he used the
geometry and that was appropriate that
he would then design the synagogue from
a geometry that was related to the
Jewish religion and this is actually
rabbi cones hands with the plan of the
synagogue superimposed over the over his
hands which Wright likened when you
entered the synagogue to be in the hands
of God so he in fact tilted the planes
of the interior so you would feel like
you were nestled in the sacred in the
sacred space and at night it truly glows
like a vessel like one of the the
vessels of light it's mounted by seven
of these almost art deco like structures
to make it more horn-like perhaps and
this is the interior which is folded
it's a hundred feet high and oddly
enough right for the ark Wright wanted
to use a burning bush motif but the
rabbi said no I don't want that I want
the phrase from the Book of Isaiah where
the Seraphim the angels each of which
have six wings hold aloft the throne of
God so in fact the rabbi very clearly
told him he wanted a Kabbalistic theme
of being within this luminous structure
that would relate in fact then to the
Merkava the the charity of God that exam
described in Ezekiel in which above was
the the color of ice above which was the
likeness of the throne and then this is
the NER Tamid is actually built into the
the abstract wings of the angel
so this and then above is which is
Kadosh
in that from that chapter in Ezekiel it
says kadosh kadosh kadosh holy holy holy
is God and then hovering above is this
almost spaceship like form which is a
microcosm of the geometry of the
synagogue and the rabbi said he actually
referred to the Zohar to the medieval
book of the Kabbalah and he mentions
five colors that the the original that
the Ain soap or the light from above is
pure white and as it comes into the
reality of of the world as we know it it
becomes different colors so we can only
understand the divine light through its
it has its trains into the colors of the
rainbow and so this is the chandelier of
light from below looking up by right
with the five colors that the rabbi
mentions from the Zohar now this is then
actually a lot of the research became
very interesting because this is the
great painter Rothko who used light as a
kind of live phenomena and I discovered
that actually if there are passages in
the Zohar that exactly illustrate for
example this painting this is from the
Zohar the blue on the second day was
tinged with other colors red and black
blue and red comes from it from the
second day itself corresponding to the
color of fire and is Elohim it inherits
the color gold for it is all one color
blue emerges from that color red when it
descends the Rend plunges deep into the
place that is the sea and has dyed blue
so whether or not Rothko who actually
was friends with Barnett Newman and
probably knew of Sheol M's book from
1941 because it was available throughout
the 50s or not he clearly was working
with a parallel idea of colors emerging
one
within the other and illustrating this
kind of divine sensibility or this is
the by Sigma or polka it's one of the
stained glass from the zurich of
cathedral again they're all sliced agate
agate stones lit from the light from
behind and recalling the idea of
Ezekiel's the eyes and the eyes within
the wheels but it also illustrates this
passage from the Zohar the universe
diffracts into 45 hues of colored light
7 dispersed into 7 abysus each one
strike against own abyss stones gyrating
the light penetrates those stones
piercing them and water issues from them
each one sinking into the abyss so
they're very strange parallels between
the Zohar and contemporary artists but I
I suppose that's the nature of mysticism
so one discovers these parallels so
after the symptom or the contraction
into the void then the emergence of
light first into vessels that then
become the pattern of the sufi wrote
these vessels now cannot contain the
divine light because they're not strong
enough to hold it
so at a certain point this cosmic
catastrophe occurs the breaking of the
vessels the vessels shatter or at least
the seven lowest vessels shatter which
has been compared to the their books
called the Big Bang and the Kabbalah
it's very much like the beginning of the
universe is the idea of the shattering
of the vessels the breaking of the
vessels and we live in the aftermath of
that broken vessels and these vessels
actually still may contain sparks of the
divine light in fact the Baal Shem Tov
said there were 288 sparks and it is
each of our obligation to raise these
sparks into T Coon
this is kusama and her this is actually
called the aftermath of the obliteration
of the universe we couldn't be more
explicitly illustration of the idea of
the the breaking of the vessels
it's a mirrored room in which these
candles are then repeated endlessly so
you enter into this mystical realm of
floating light that is that is that
implies an original hole from which it
broke this is by also by Anselm Kiefer
called the Shiva radically more the
breaking of the vessels who uses that
term explicitly where you have these
broken vessels lying at the bottom of
this pit in his in the studio space that
he created outside of Paris or this is
Daniel II busken's
diagram for the Imperial War Museum in
Manchester where he also uses the idea
of the globe that has been shattered and
broken into shards like as war does and
these shards that he then isolates three
of them he calls one the air the earth
and the water shard to create this
museum to house exhibits on the history
of war but that is the nature of these
broken vessels of this shattered order
that we have to repair this is Cornelia
Parker a British artist who blew up this
shed and then reassembled it with a
light in the center so it looks like the
idea of a frozen a state of
deconstruction now finally the theme of
repair or tycoon where it is the idea of
the obligation of each individual to
help repair the universe and it's taken
on the idea of doing anything charitable
but the original meaning had to do with
the observance of the 613 commandments
of observing rituals so that because one
does not know when the final spark will
be raised back and the universe will be
brought back into its original sense of
hole so it creates a great burden on
individuals how does one illustrate this
in architecture this was this is the
neue gallery in Berlin this is by David
Chipperfield took this museum that was
destroyed during the Second World War
but rather than recreated completely so
that it would look like no time had
passed and that the memory would be
erased he combined elements of the old
and the new so this is the same view of
the stair hall rather than recreate the
statues and the elaborate wall surfaces
he left them he stripped them as a kind
of container within which is placed this
new stair that is abstract and creates
this dialogue between the the old and
the new to create kind of something that
is in suspended animation Beach that is
usable as a museum but is haunting in
the sense of maintaining the memory
repair but something that one recalls
what happened before and again in the
exhibits you see the walls the original
walls of the museum in fact before the
plaster and the paintings were put on
with exhibits that are crisp and modern
and glass and steel as a kind of
creating this dialogue and then this
very striking synagogue in Mainz Germany
by Manuel Hertz a German architect was
recreated on the site of the one that
was destroyed during Kristallnacht
during in 1939 when many synagogues were
burnt and in a sense was the beginning
of the Holocaust so on that same site
the idea of tycoon is is explored
through a synagogue that maintains the
ruin but build something new adjacent to
it that takes on actually
the silhouette of the Hebrew letters
Kadosh or holy and mind of Immanuel
Hertz explains that there is that the
history of Judaism because Jews were
went from were expelled from place to
place they never really had time to
develop their own architecture so
writing became the equivalent of their
architectural constructions so as we saw
the idea of the magic of the Hebrew
letters here he uses very explicitly the
idea of the outline of the Kadosh for
the the section of the synagogue and the
entire interior is actually covered in
letters that are inscribed on the walls
which is the equivalent of the safer
your tiara which is one of the pre
Kabbalistic books that talk about the
universe was carved out by 32 paths of
wisdom the 22 letters of the Hebrew
alphabet which became the the tools by
which the universe was created and the
tensity wrote so this and in fact light
pours through the openings of the the
Kadosh to create the synagogue
so here the letters are the shape of the
architecture and inside it's all of
various angles almost like the shards
after the the breaking of the vessels
that are then reassembled in this
illustration of tikkun and finally not
essential but one of the more colorful
ideas of Kabbalah is the golem which is
the the idea of the artificial creation
of life through the use of Hebrew
letters and God's name and so it's
actually comes from a commentary on the
safer your tiara which says that there
was a recipe for creating the Golem that
one would put various ingredients
together and then write Hebrew letters
on top of this and recite a mystical
prayer and then life would be created
so this predates the idea of
Frankenstein on the other hand it looks
forward to artificial intelligence in
fact Ray Kurzweil who was the head of
Google AI had a dialogue with rabbi
Stein Salt's who was one of the great
contemporary Kabbalists about this very
subject so Kabbalah as esoteric as it
seems touches on many topics that have
yet to even be explored this is the
golem by Robert Wilson which then cracks
open in which inside is someone dressed
as a Hasidic person for a and then this
is by three artists who very clearly
show the idea of the Hebrew alphabet
this spells M ed or truth if we remove
the olive which the Emmet creates the
Golem when you remove the off it comes
mate or death so he then stops but this
is Adam Adam so the again at the idea of
the magic and power of the Hebrew
letters this is the Golem from 1922 from
the film that Hans pulchik a Great
Architect actually did all the sets for
and then finally one might ask and I'll
conclude how can one create a golem of
architecture and so these are these are
colorful inventive shapes that John
Hajduk who was the Dean of Cooper Union
he designed these animated figures of
architecture in 1995 each one with a
interesting outfit and they like a
circus troupe would would prance through
the countryside and it was only Frank
Gehry who is able to create a real
architectural golem in of all places
Prague which was the home of the famous
golem of rabbi Lowe and this was a this
building actually is called Fred and
Ginger where you have Fred as the
upright element and Ginger
so the couple dancing the idea of the
implicit animated architecture
architectural
live which is with its own soul again
showing the concept of how Kabbalah can
touch all aspects of our lives so thank
you very much any questions or yeah well
than you who I must say yes Frank
Goldberg ever designed anything else on
the Kabbalistic theme yes Frank Goldberg
was his original name yes from Canada
and he changed it to Gary which he
thought was less Jewish but did he do
any other well I think he for example I
think the plan of Bilbao is based on a
rose and the beginning of the Zohar
talks about the rose within a rose
within a rose and the rose of Israel so
I I do think there are themes actually I
I go back I asked him directly because
when I was doing research for this book
I knew him from Cooper Union and I saw
him at a lecture and I said have you
ever studied the Zohar he said well you
know I tried but it was too difficult he
said he said however and he claimed that
Teddy Kollek who was the mayor of Israel
in 1967
I mean mayor of a Jerusalem in 1967
after the 67 war he had the great idea
to reconstruct the Third Temple and he
asked Gary to do that and Gary said well
I don't really want to do the Temple but
I'd like to do the base with the hotels
and the restaurants and all that so but
uh so he did acknowledge that he's aware
of that and he's also friends with Margo
Pritzker who funded the translation of
the Zohar into English by daniel matt
who is a great scholar from Berkeley
California
I haven't looked into the Kabbalistic
implications of that thank you for what
wonderful talk
sometimes when I'm looking at the cup
Kabbalistic tree it seems to me that the
middle the middle sphere oat is tea
ferret or beauty and I wondered if he
was an artist or if these other artists
who work with Kabbalah took any
particular inspiration from that that
that idea of beauty could be central I
think that's a very good point that yes
the central Sufi road in which they all
coalesce or the upper part intersect is
beauty so I think I think in a way there
was a implication from the beginning
that that beauty and art are at the
heart of creation so which is why you
have the Michelangelo illustrating the
creation of mankind from as the
beginning of you know at the Sistine
Chapel thank you very much
I was recently in Barcelona at the
Lister gotta Familia and I noticed some
things that struck me as Kabbalistic in
nature and some of those stuff with the
with the lighting I can't imagine it was
intentional but I wonder whether you are
aware of any churches or other kinds of
religious places of worship that utilize
any of these aspects because there is a
rich history to Christian Hembree ISM
and Christian yes cupola so I haven't
studied that in-depth but in
contemporary architecture for example
today oh and oh did a church of the
light in Japan in which he literally cut
out across through the concrete and so
in this case the light is creating the
form which in a way illustrates that
idea
the of the vessels of light so I think
it's you know their illness illustrative
themes but I'm not aware in earlier and
probably in the Renaissance there was
because there is a great theme of a
history of Christian Kabbalah as well
which I didn't touch on here
at the risk of asking you to repeat
yourself I had a similar question some
of the artistic examples you showed
certainly predated the 20th century but
almost all of the I think all of the
architectural examples were not just
20th century but post Holocaust and you
earlier in your talk referenced the
importance of the Holocaust to one of
the artists I'm wondering if there is
some connection between the the kind of
willingness to sort of bring Kabbalah
into a kind of design vocabulary and the
Holocaust or are there or were you sort
of deliberately focusing on 20th century
examples and there are there are
architectural examples that run deeper
well though I think it is a post
holocaust thing insofar as it was really
show limbs book on Jewish mysticism that
brought to an english-speaking audience
many of these themes that previously
were not accessible I mean there were
books that were translated into English
in the nineteenth century but they were
often mixed up in theosophy and the
order of the Golden Dawn and Madame
Blavatsky and it was it was a much more
kind of essay it was a different
tradition that was apart from I don't
want to say mainstream Judaism but
something that was dissociated from this
kind of as Yeats said mystic mumbo jumbo
in a way so I think that and I think the
painters who studied this really were
the ones who then brought it to the fore
like Newman so I think that was what
kind of sparked the interest in these
Kabbalistic themes in contemporary but I
mean since the 50s I would say and it's
it's really growing what's it's
interesting is because it's really
contemporary phenomenon it's not
something that was apparent earlier I
would say
I mean that Daniel maths translation has
just been completed this year really and
I think it's one of the most poetic
translations of the of the Zohar
actually that's available and also just
by talking about it then people are for
example I asked Steven Holl a Columbia
architect if he was I said he did this
church actually would say it's a
Catholic chapel in Seattle and it's
literally he described it as vessels of
light a series of vessels of life and
it's I asked him because I know also
know him a little bit I said did you
study any of garam masala he said
absolutely so he claimed I think it's
part of a kind of general education at
this point that people are now aware of
these themes and it becomes you know at
Stevens level let's say something had
that he's interested in anyway and it
just it's a reconfirmation of some of
these ideas
yeah
but though I think that the the gender
dualism is definitely something that
people are now looking into the Kabbalah
in more detail and that the Zohar is
filled with all sorts of sexual passages
about the union of God and mankind and
the Shekinah and so it's very much
involved with gender and different
levels of connection both sexual and
spiritual
well I don't know who that was but you
have to tell me
okay all right thank you Oh so yes um I
just find it amazing how um some of
these structures that are more
contemporary and modern like have died
um sleek ambiance but compared to the
cathedrals and some of the museums that
truly have like a deeper sense of
history um they seem more infinite and
they seem like they would last many ages
compared to structures like this even
though as you have said this one resided
from like history of like the golems and
things like that but um like a learner
like me or as anyone else in this room
how could could you say um I could find
some kind of enticing reason to look
deeper into contemporary more modern
like structures because they do have
that um historic sense but like not as
as it draws compared to like cathedrals
and churches well I would say the the
best of contemporary architects also
create work that reverberates throughout
history that it recalls various
historical examples but reinterpreted in
a way I mean I'm it's hard to compete
with Chartres Cathedral but I mean it's
I think in a different way it's like
looking at contemporary art and we're
like looking at Barnett Newman is a it's
abstract it's very simple or Mondrian
but it has its own distinct Sensibility
that the greatest of which I think holds
up to anything of the past but in a
totally different way
all right thank you so much thank you
[Applause]